[Music]
hey everyone welcome to their
installments of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing the weasley twins fred and
george more specifically we're going to
be discussing the differences between
the pair fred and george are the fourth
and fifth born children of arthur and
molly weasley they were born in the year
1978 and it's probably no surprise to
anyone to their identical twins this
means that they're physically identical
in nearly every way however the twins
are extra similar in that they also
share very similar personality traits in
fact most of the time it's hard to tell
them apart given that they are so
similar today i want to explore how we
can actually determine which one is
which additionally i wanted to take a
look at their individual contributions
to the series to see if one twin is more
significant than the other from the
perspective of the story only first
things first one has to be older right
well yeah it turns out that when they
were born on april 1 1978 fred popped
out first so he must be the older wiser
brother right tragically fred was also
the first of the brothers to die
suffering an untimely death during the
battle of hogwarts jk rowling has
revealed that fred's death was one of
the hardest to write in however she did
also reveal that fred was the chosen
brother to die because he was slightly
more conspicuous suggesting that fred
plays a slightly larger role in the
books films than george
actually it turns out that fred is
mentioned over 900 times in the books
while george is only mentioned around
700 times the reason for this is not
entirely clear
however it may be because fred is the
slightly more vocal brother the one who
is more likely to act and speak first
from pottermore when you read through
the books you can see that it was almost
always fred who spoke first usually a
joke or dramatic comment he was the
front man the lead singer the one who
first got everyone's attention
george was the slightly more
level-headed twin who explained what his
brother actually meant fred even passed
george the task of explaining the
marauders map to harry when he could
have done so himself
in fact while harrig was close to both
of the twins he had longer conversations
with george who often explained events
harry might have missed plans he and
fred had or things harry didn't quite
understand fred and george really did
complement each other perfectly
additionally fred was the instigator for
most of their pranks george simply
followed suit whenever the weasley twins
did something particularly naughty it
always seemed to be fred who took the
lead when the twins and ron broke harry
out of privet drive in his second year
it was fred who was driving the flying
ford anglia he was usually the one
behind even the smaller pranks fred was
the one who liberated a salamander from
care of magical creatures so they could
try to feed it filibuster firework and
fred was the one who accidentally
dropped a ton tongue toffee in front of
dudley did you ever notice that it's
always fred and george not george and
fred fred spoke first and george
explained second which almost makes
george's circumstances after fred's
death even sadder the two were
inseparable for their entire lives and
provided that fred was the front man
george was probably quite lost after the
war after years of following the actions
of his twin and never really having to
take action himself
in life they spent nearly every waking
moment together they had a beautiful
friendship and interestingly enough the
books don't really delve much into what
actually happened to george after the
death of his brother losing any kind of
friend or family member is horrendous
but to lose a twin must be soul
destroying after the death of fred what
happened to george in the documentary jk
rowling a year in the life rowling dives
into the weasley family tree and
mentions the following with regards to
george a lot of readers ask me was
george all right and of course he
wouldn't be all right would he that's
the reality but i think that he married
angelina who was actually fred's ex
maybe it's a bit unhealthy but i think
they would have been happy as happy as
he could be without fred i think he
really would have felt like part of
himself died additionally rowling was
asked about george weasley's state in a
2007 interview with bloomsbury how was
george getting along without his twin
well i don't think that george would
ever get over losing fred which makes me
feel so sad however he names his first
child and son fred and he goes on to
have a very successful career helped by
good old ron
the interview also confirms that george
continued working at the business which
he and his brother had created ron
joined george at weasley's wizarding
wheezes which became an enormous money
spinner these are quite tragic answers
from rowling but it's good to see that
she isn't softening the truth losing a
family member is one of the worst things
that we have to deal with in life
effectively yes life would go on for
george but it would never be the same
his companion the person that he had
shared every moment with since childhood
was gone would he be happy again would
he experience joy again yes of course
but would george weasley be changed
forever after the passing of his brother
absolutely so how else did these twin
brothers who were nearly identical in
every way operate as individuals while
fred was a bit more outgoing and
inclined to do a bit of damage him and
george were almost the perfect combo
because george was always there to
mitigate the damage however don't get me
wrong george was happy to do so he would
have never wanted his twins demeanor to
change and was happy to take on damage
control after his brother opened his
mouth fred and george were both
undeniably charismatic but george was as
it were the public face of the weezy
twins able to be much more subtle and
diplomatic than fred george was the twin
who made edits their letter to ludo
bagman knowing that certain wording
would sound accusatory and was the one
who realized why hermione wanted to get
into the school kitchens he was even the
one who remembered to get the new common
room password from a prefect but not
only were their personalities different
they were also unsurprisingly not
identical in athletic performance
athleticism will vary largely on an
individual basis and it just so happens
that george was the better athlete what
game quidditch what position beta while
both fred and george were excellent
beaters and a credit to the gryffindor
quidditch team there were more mentions
of george hitting bludgers than there
were of fred george seemed to be the
slightly more aggressive of the two on
the quidditch pitch described once as
hitting a bludger at a player as a way
of venting his feelings and retaliating
for a foul by elbowing a slytherin beta
in the face
lastly i want to explore if there's a
way to tell them apart physically are
there any key differences that can help
us to spot which one is which this next
part is going to be exploring the
characters from the films as the
real-life actors oliver and james phelps
do in fact have some subtle differences
in their physical appearance for
reference oliver plays george and james
plays fred i got the following
information from a source i've never
heard of online so hopefully it's
accurate
it turns out that george oliver has a
longer straighter and slightly thinner
face the slightly differently set jaw he
also has a mole on the right side of his
neck has slightly more slanted eyes that
are less deep has a slightly longer and
curved nose with a bump has a slightly
crooked smile and is slightly taller
than fred
james fred can be characterized by a
shorter rounder face a scar on his left
eyebrow less slanted deeper eyes a
straight nose and a slightly shorter
stature and i think that about
summarizes all the differences between
fred george did you guys learn something
i know that i didn't know all of this
until researching for the video did
anything surprise you let me know in the
comment section below until next time
remember ask us no questions and will
tell you no lies
[Music]
[Music]
you